this video is the first one on the
channel by dalire Mei is a guru tutor a
game developer a young engineer and he's
really serious about providing very good
quality you can see that to the source
code the demo that he made for this
tutorial we're starting with a simple
tutorial about how to work with
different screen sizes in Godot please
welcome him hello everyone I know that
my voice sounds a little bit different
and that is because I'm not actually
Natan my name is Gilly I mean you can
also call me G if that's easier and you
can expect to see me here on different
videos on the channel this one we are
going to learn how to prepare our game
and configure it to work with different
screen resolutions now that can affect
your gameplay if you don't do it
correctly if I play this game you'll
notice that we have a really small
screen
it's 640 by 480 which gives us an aspect
ratio of 4 by 3 and the main purpose of
the game is to try to avoid these green
Goblin's by using the buttons on the
screen right now if I try to click on
the maximize button here you notice that
everything is going to go to the top
left of our game screen and our buttons
will keep the same places that they were
before but everything looks weird we
don't have the same that we had before
we can also see where the enemies are
spawning so the player is seeing more
than he actually needs to see and more
than we actually want him to see and
that is because we never told the engine
how to deal with screen or different
screen resolutions and to do that I have
to go to the project settings go to the
bottom until you find a display and
select the window and here on the bottom
you'll see that on the stretch the mode
is disabled and we can select 2d or
viewport here
if we select 2d the aim when we resize
it is going to be rendered on a
different resolution but if we select
the viewport the resolution is basically
going to be the same but is just going
to be bigger imagine this as if you had
a really small picture and you started
to zoom into it that's basically the
same effect for now I'm going to like 2d
and keep the aspect as ignore and I'm
going to plating him and maximize it so
you can see what this gives us
now as you can see because I'm playing
this game on a sixteen by nine monitor
widescreen monitor everything is wider
that is because we are ignoring the
aspect of our game now also I want you
to play attention here to the buttons
you can see that we don't have anything
pixelated but if I go back to the
headings and instead of using 2d I
decide to use viewport we're going to
get the fact that I told you before
which was zooming into a small picture
if I maximize the game again everything
is pixelated so this is basically the
difference that we have from 2d to
viewport and it's up to you to decide
which one works best for your game
now if I decide to keep the aspect ratio
of our game so if I decide to keep this
four by three aspect video I'm also
going to change the mode to beauty again
the engine is going to keep the four by
three aspect ratio doesn't matter in
which resolution or which aspect video
we are playing our game in and it's
going to add black borders to the top
and bottom are to left and right
depending on the size of our monitor and
the size of the screen of the game is
being played at right now if instead of
using keep I decide to use keep with
what's gonna happen is that we'll be
able to see more on the vertical axis of
our game it's always gonna try to keep
the same width that we had when we begin
a game and if instead of using keep with
we decided to keep the height what's
gonna happen is the opposite so we're
going to get more resolution on the
horizontal pane here we'll be able to
see more of the game from the x-axis and
depending on the type of game that you
have this is going to give an advantage
for some players doesn't matter which
one you choose for instance here in this
game here I can see where the enemy is
being found and this gives me more time
to respond to this and if I was not
using a bigger resolution or a wider
resolution I wouldn't be able to see
that enemies coming from the right so
easily so I would have less time to
react to these events
and to finish everything the last option
that you have is to use instead of keep
height or keep width and choose expand
and is going to try to keep the same
aspect video that we had before but it's
going to add more screen either
vertically or horizontally
as you can see right here so this can
lead to some really unexpected behavior
right now I can see more of the right of
the game but if you had a monitor that
it was in widescreen and was actually
taller you'd be able to see more of the
bottom of the game so you don't really
know what's gonna happen when you hand
this to a different screen so a little
little tricky to use but again this all
depends on the type of game that you
have and if it's going to really give
you a big impact on how it's going to be
played so I always keep this in mind
sometimes you're giving the player the
option to see more of some parts of the
game and this can again give some
advantages to some of them and some
disadvantages for some of the players as
well
and that's the thing that you should
keep in mind when you're dealing with
different screen sizes is how your UI
elements are going to be set up the
touch buttons right here are anchored to
the bottom of our game that's why when
we played it and we maximized it the
game window everything kind of took the
same place that it was before but if I
change this and I can select all of them
here using this touch button the scene
and click on the layout go to the
anchors only and I decide to anchor them
to the center top of our screen it's
basically going to try to always keep
the same position by using a calculation
from the top here of the screen to the
bottom and if I play you notice that now
when I increase the size of the game
they are going they are not going to go
neither to the left or the right and if
the game was actually tolerate instead
of wider they're going to keep the same
place that they were before we can play
around with this right here I'm not
going to go through all of them but each
one of them is going to give you a
different configuration for the UI when
you resize your game so that's also
something to keep in mind when you are
dealing with different screen
resolutions and that was it for this
video if you have any questions please
feel free to ask me on the comments
section and if you want to play around
with this project right here and try
things on your own you can go to the
video description and you'll find a link
for the github repository where you'll
be able to download it and run it on
your machine thank you so much for
watching and I hope to see you guys
again soon